ils ont repris le travail ce matin
coutelas et débroussailleuses en main
cet agent du parc naturel de martinique
au secours de ces caféiers nous sommes
sur une parcelle expérimentale du morne
vert une petite commune du nord caraïbes
quelque peu épargnée par la sécheresse
est plein de café c'est des arbres assez
à des armes us assez délicat il faut
tout le temps les nettoyer pour comment
dirais-je pour pour la croissance ou
qu'ils aient une bonne croissance ok pas
de gêne à l'avenir pour la floraison
tout ça ça demande beaucoup de soin ici
au mont nevers apparemment ça s'est bien
passé de l'état des plantes que j'ai
constaté je lui ça va le carême ça n'a
pas trop affecté les plans une reprise
du travail en gardant néanmoins en
mémoire les gestes barrières liées au
kobus 19 même en pleine nature
ils portent des masques chacun ils ont
un protocole sip à respecter pour le
respect des jet de barrières pour la
distanciation social pour effectivement
le change le change des masques pour un
petit peu l'élégant apporté alors ce qui
facilité pour nous ici c'est que comme
ils sont en pleine nature
donc c'est vrai que il ya quand même une
aisance au niveau du déplacement de
l'espacement et tout cela 300 arbustes
au total et des parcelles sous
surveillance depuis au moins trois ans
nous avons une exploitation
expérimentale particulièrement ici donc
il était important pour nous de bien
soigner cette exploitation là puisque
c'est là que nous pouvons juger
effectivement la bonne croissance de la
plante que nous pouvons regarder
effectivement le niveau de traitement
qu'il faudra porter traitement naturel
surtout qu'il rapporte à la plante
donc tout cela méritait effectivement
qu'on porte une attention particulière
donc nous sommes revenus en avant pour
pouvoir travailler sur les exploitations
ce café l'arabica atypique à a déjà
donné des fouilles 70 kg sont d'ores et
déjà prêts notamment pour une clientèle
japonaise
si tout va bien et une autre récolte est
prévue en septembre